Buen día Raúl esa tercer emoción de
vacancia presidencial contra Pedro
Castillo lo acusa de haber resignado
funcionarios con graves cuestionamientos
para favorecer a intereses de su entorno
también acogiendo las investigaciones en
la fiscalía se lo responsabiliza por
dirigir supuestamente una organización
criminal y haber cometido presuntos
delitos de tráfico de influencias y
colusión también además de esto se lo
procesa por el cuestionados manejos en
los ascensos de la policía y las fuerzas
armadas es así que un breve mensaje a
los peruanos anoche el presidente Pedro
Castillo rechazó las acusaciones en su
contra y señaló que afrontará este
tercer pedido de vacancia presidencial
que según su parecer está basado en
dichos de terceros quienes según el
mandatario tratando de acogerse a
beneficios de la fiscalía lo estarían
tratando de responsabilizar sin ningún
tipo de pruebas cuando podemos esperar
una decisión sobre este tema Francisco
esta tarde a las quince horas Lima
Bogotá se inicia el impeachmen en el
parlamento peruano y tras un largo
debate se espera que esta noche Se
conozca el resultado aún no existe la
certeza que si la oposición que en el
congreso es dirigida por la derecha
pueda conseguir los 87 votos que son
necesarios para retirar a Pedro castillo
del cargo tampoco ha sido confirmada la
presencia del mandatario peruano para
ejercer su derecho a réplica lo que sí
Hasta el momento ya han sido acreditados
sus abogados Benji Espinoza y José
Palomino para ejercer la defensa
paralelamente a esto la primer ministra
peruana Betsy Chávez también ha pedido
la participación de cuatro ministros del
gabinete Para apoyar en esta defensa de
Pedro Castillo nosotros estaremos
atentos a la jornada y estaremos
ampliando la información en las
emisiones de France 24
Francisco una Una última pregunta cómo
afronta el presidente Castillo este
tercer impeachmen del Congreso de Perú
no eh Cómo está Castillo para poder
defenderse
bueno en esos momentos Pedro Castillo se
encuentra en una situación política muy
débil porque en las últimas horas han
aparecido denuncias de un ex colaborador
del servicio de inteligencia que señala
que su sobrino le habría pedido dinero a
cambio de nombrar a funcionarios también
se señala que una empresaria ha acusado
al mandatario peruano de a través de
asesores haber solicitado alrededor de
un millón de dólares a cambio de
beneficios para
una licitación de construcción de unas
obras en estos momentos Pedro Castillo
está en una situación muy débil hay más
de un 71% de los peruanos según una
última encuesta que está a favor de que
haya una destitución del mandatario
peruano a través del impeachment dicho
sea de paso también el parlamento de
Perú que va a ejecutar este proceso
Tampoco cuenta con las preferencias de
los peruanos es por eso que también hay
otra tercera versión de la población que
pide que se vayan todos tanto el
presidente como los congresi